I almost cut the lights off in the
studio tonight you know cause it's you
know I'm making this it's nighttime and
this gonna be ready for you guys in a
few hours but almost cut the lights off
man cuz some of my like feeling that
romance boy and the funny thing is I
noticed even if I cut the lights off
even if I'm by myself I can feel a like
a little bit of romance you know I can
feel like a little bit of romance kind
of come just kind of just just tickling
my tits a little you know like I just
like you try this man if you put on put
a shawl around your neck you know put
like a soft cloth around your neck or
even if you can't afford a soft cloth or
a shawl or a you know a scarf nothing
heavy don't get one of those heavy ass
scarfs you know don't show up in a heavy
yeah you look like an idiot I'd go to
soft scarfs before I go one heavy scarf
you know one heavy scarf that's some
amistad type [ __ ] you know those days
are over
okay go go to soft scarfs and give us
free but I love uh but if you put on and
if you don't have a scarf get you some
paper towels get you a like about nine
paper towels or eight people eight paper
towels in a row okay take your shirt off
you know take your shirt off if you are
a man or a woman take your shirt off all
right it doesn't matter you know some
people have chest
some people have tits you know tits is
just fat chest that's all that is you
know and and chest is just uh lean tits
that's this you know and some people
have either one you know my mother had
their makeups than baby A's and so I
didn't see a lot of tit around the house
even if you know even if sometimes you
know sometimes when you're growing up if
you're a child and your mother have nice
breasts you get that free that free
visual you know you get that oh okay you
know even though it's your mother you
you know you're not being like that but
you still get that hit but my mother had
them a
cups you know so it was more you know it
wasn't as I didn't get those voluptuous
visuals around the house but what I'm
saying is this you know is that romance
can be achieved even by oneself
everybody thinking oh I got to have
somebody to be romantic you know I got
to meet somebody on the internet and you
know and meet up with them somewhere you
know in a parking lot or something to be
romantic well that's [ __ ] those are
the old days you know nowadays here's
something you can do around your house
even if you're alone cut the lights down
put a few candles around your house
don't put a bunch of candles okay
especially if you don't use candles a
lot because you're somebody that's gonna
probably burn to death so just use a
couple of candles you know put them
around and then get you them um if you
put on a law a soft scarf or even two
really soft scarfs or get you a long
string of paper towels put that around
your neck and now just kind of glide
around your house a little bit make sure
the children are asleep or whatever you
know put a couple candles and just kind
of like you know lean against a wall
somewhere and be like Oh fancy seeing
you here you know or open the
refrigerator and just take a hit off
that coolness feel the you know feel
that cold air just [ __ ] tickle your
titty ends you know you can make romance
wherever you want just be like oh what
was that in the distance even if it was
nothing even if it was just a puppy over
there touching his little dick or
something with his paws scratching
himself you know I'm saying you can make
romance wherever everybody acts like we
got to do this or got to do that to make
romance but you can make your own
romance and that's something that I'm
starting to realize in my life that just
because maybe if I don't have love in my
life at some point it doesn't mean that
I can't create romance in my life you
could do something nice for yourself get
you a couple of them uh you know
Valentines
they got a good deal on chocolates out
there go get out there and get a 40 pack
of chocolates man and you can get those
have you two or three give something to
a neighbor
now suddenly you eatin chocolates with
someone you know you can make your own
romance and I'm not saying that I'm not
trying to get people to be alone I don't
want people to be alone you know we got
this world right now that's just pushing
us to be alone
they just advertise and everything you
know do you do you do you where
everybody doing themselves in this and
then you you got no friends
you got no friend you don't have anybody
to borrow a shirt from or anybody to
borrow some sugar from but if you happen
to be by yourself that doesn't mean that
you can't have a little bit of romance
in your life you know I do different
things sometimes I'll put my pants in
the dryer and then put them on my legs
what is that ooh daddy got them hot
sticks hanging off his hips now you can
treat yourself to different things you
can do different things for yourself to
get that romance and this is the time of
year to do it
you know because spring is in the air
they got that love they got that nest
you know if you get outside or earlier
something you hear birds in the distance
you know to [ __ ] or even just you
know petting each other heavily you know
you'll hear baby birds out there waiting
for that worm you know you could see
even some hookers are out there even
hookers are happy in the spring you ever
notice that you get a wintertime hooker
I'm saying you get that December escort
that lady ain't fired up
she ain't excited about the potential
[ __ ] money that could be headed her
way but you get out here you know you
know you get out here at these times and
and ladies are fired up you know if
they're working out on the streets even
ladies are fired up as it's springtime
and love is in the air ah
but I'm trying to create some romance
for myself you know I'm trying to create
some romance because we have to do you
know you go through times your life
where you know I feel you go through
times you in life where you don't have
that love were you getting to bed at
night and you just kick your legs out
across the other side of the bed and
there's nobody there
you know you just you just swimming out
there like like that Nirvana baby and
that album cover you just swimming out
there you know and you want somebody you
want to have that other say you know you
want to have a little bit of love in
your life but they but that doesn't mean
you can't be romantic you know you could
still do romance a little bit and that's
one thing I would do from time to time
is I would you know wear something kind
of sexy even for a man you know
everybody acts like only women can have
sexy clothing or do something sexy but a
man can wear sexy stuff you know you
could wear some really large pants or
something well thanks for watching that
video right there that was a beautiful
little segment I think but of course i'm
partisan to myself but you can move on
to another video right now you could
check on this video or on this video
that's two different options and you can
also subscribe to the channel check on a
new video subscribe to the channel check
subscribe subscribe